I am managers Armour Captain America as
a shield and spider-man as his
web-shooters
but there are few superheroes who are as
strongly identified with their equipment
as Thor for centuries he's been depicted
wielding as my team Ionia whose crushing
blows resound with the sound of thunder
across the nine realms but in the comics
that's not the only weapon that God of
Thunder is wielded against the forces of
evil join us as we take a trip through
the Asgardian armory to rank Thor's
Hammer's from weakest to strongest
ultimate Leonia one the original version
of me or Nia that we saw in the pages of
The Ultimates wasn't actually me or near
at all instead in keeping with that
books questions about whether Thor was
actually a god or just some delusional
but super-powered Norwegian gentleman it
was the product of technology not magic
Wally would eventually turn out to be
the earthly incarnation of the god of
thunder
Thor's original set of equipment was
based entirely on super science with a
weather controlling costume powered by a
battery inside a giant hammer while it
was certainly formidable it was far from
flawless as a weapon made by humans that
liked both the sheer power of the
magical Nyonya and the enchantments are
made Thor the only one able to use it
that made it pretty easy for villains to
replicate including a Soviet super
soldier who paired his hammer with a
similarly powerful sickle because comics
have never exactly been subtle ultimate
me Oh nyet so after spending a few years
swinging around his teleological hammer
who thought the ultimate universe got
his hands on the genuine article like
the core universes version of my own
eeeh this version granted its wielder
incredible powers most of which involved
the ability to smash problems into a
fine red mist it did not however have
the worthiness enchantments or anything
else I could keep bad guys like the
ultimate universe's genocide or version
of Magneto from picking it up needless
to say this caused a lot of problems
when it found its way to the core marvel
universe it was used by Volstagg one of
Thor's closest Asgardian allies when he
have to dit in order to defend his realm
the noble but definitely past his prime
warrior wasn't just turned into Thor he
was turned into an incredibly powerful
version called war Thor
unfortunately that transformation also
made him prone to violent rages and when
it was destroyed by mangog left a
Volstagg in a coma a pretty high price
to pay just to use a hammer that's also
an axe
yarn beyond wall is technically not a
hammer young beyond definitely deserves
a spot on the list the Odinson wheeled
the sacks in the days before he proved
his worthiness of Nyonya and more
recently when he found himself unworthy
once again while it lacks me Anya's
ability to channel lightning is still a
gigantic magic battle axe crafted by the
gods that alone makes it pretty
formidable and allows it to live up to
the meaning of its name the iron bear
it's incredibly sharp can slash through
the armor of the space gods known as the
Celestials and was also enchanted to be
at least as indestructible as the
original me or Nia it's worth noting
that yarn beyond most memorable powerful
moments isn't exactly one of its best
the first time methought took it into
battle after losing his hammer it was
taken away from him by Malekith hoop
Romney used it to cut off Thor's arm
that's the sort of thing that's going to
happen when you're used to swinging
around the weapon no one else can left
but any weapon that can almost
effortlessly separate God's limbs has to
be pretty potent the golden hammer after
my own ears destruction Thor contacted a
dwarven blacksmith named screw beard and
got him to make a new hammer the bad
news is that this hammer broke on its
first outing when four shattered it by
hitting the unstoppable juggernaut the
good news is that screw beard had made
plenty of backup hammers and teleported
an entire ass north of Thor eventually
he found one that would stand up to some
heavy use the golden hammer is still new
enough that it hasn't been named yet
although scrooby had mentioned that one
of the other destroyed hammers was
called Hulk's miter so it's difficult to
judge its true power it has however been
mentioned in the comics that is made of
a less pure form of the metal or arrow
and likely won't hold up as well as he
original Mjolnir dead me onea the
original Mjolnir has long been
considered one of the Marvel universe's
most powerful artifacts and for good
reason even if it was just an
indestructible room mullet empowered by
the odinforce
it would be a pretty respectable weapon
but that's just the tip of this
particular enchanted iceberg what really
makes me Oni is so powerful is that it's
directly tied into the power and godhood
of thor the enchantments on the hammer
means that anyone worthy enough can
truly become the god of thunder by
lifting her including jane foster beta
ray bill and even Loki but while Mjolnir
weathered plenty of figurative and
literal storms and it's time I wouldn't
probably should have asked about a
lifetime warranty in the
hello crushed it into bits and in the
comics it was destroyed when Thor Jane
Foster took it into battle again see
otherwise and stoppable mangog launching
it and the villain into the Sun the only
thing that survived was a pebble sized
chunk of arrow that was still pretty
difficult for the unworthy to left still
he had to give it credit a hammer that
can only be destroyed by something
that's 27 million degrees Fahrenheit and
constantly exploding with nuclear
reactions isn't exactly fragile
Stormbreaker in the movies Stormbreaker
restores devastating new groot handle
hammer but in the comics it belongs to
beta ray bill he's an alien hero who
once found himself battling for and
drawing the fight he was able to prove
his worthiness by lifting the hammer and
briefly taking over the identity of Thor
after Odin decreed that the two heroes
would battle to the death to determine
who would get the hammer and the title
about all that bill actually weren't
bill once again proved himself by saving
Thor's life and swore an oath to be an
ally and oath brother to reward his
valor and cement the Alliance Odin
granted him Stormbreaker a new golden
hammer set to be me only as equal in
every way so if they're equals why does
Stormbreaker rank higher simple Leonia
got destroyed but storm breakers still
around being in one piece tends to give
it a bit of an edge
[Music]